i'll talk to anybody if you have a
problem with me i'll talk to you anytime
anyplace anywhere you can bring a
hundred people
and i'll debate you by myself now are
there jokes i've made that i wish i
didn't and are
perceived differently now of course but
i've been doing this for 20 years
so i might maybe i wish i could do that
but i know my character
and our intent has always been to make
people laugh period
dave portnoy founder president or rather
el presidente as he calls himself a bar
stool sports the digital brand and news
site for all things sports and pop
culture
brought to you by the common fan for the
common fan
dave is chief of all content but his
candid emergency press conferences
his very public opinions on past
employees and his unpredictable business
moves make him a fascinating character
for the job
and unlike anybody else scrappy
beginnings built a following around
barstool not online but
actually in good old-fashioned print
which included dave himself driving all
around boston delivering the publication
that was back in 2003 dave's approach
aside from the sheer power of will
was appealing to sports fans in ways
that major publications and
networks simply weren't making bar stool
a mainstay in the market
fast forward nearly 20 years and
barstool is on the bleeding edge of
digital content
they boast over 50 podcasts with several
top performers on podcast charts
last time i checked barstool's caller
daddy was number one on apple podcast
one of their newest achievements is the
barstool sportsbook mobile app creating
an easy to use sports gambling
experience in the palm of your hand
we'll discuss what the process has been
like getting mobile sports gambling
available countrywide over the last year
we'll also discuss how dave's pizza
reviews became a thing his fundraising
of 37 million dollars to save small
business
the story behind interviewing president
trump and a whole lot more
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn it's time to
stand up to big tech protect your data
at expressvpn.com
just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with dave the
only way to get access to that part of
the conversation is to become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests dave portnoy
thanks so much for stopping by thanks
for having me
all right so let's start with your
business philosophy since i think that
you're one of the more unique guys in
business today of this big crossover
audience a lot of conservatives love you
a lot of people on the left love you
but it seems like your business
philosophy is generally i don't give
a crap but you run this incredibly
successful business so what exactly is
your business philosophy
if i had to narrow it down into a quick
sentence probably follow my gut
that's what i've been doing since i
started it and it's worked so far so i
hear a lot of times people like what are
you doing this for why are you doing
that
but we just follow our gut it's
sometimes right sometimes not
but there isn't some grand business plan
or philosophy that
you know we're following we're quick to
pivot when we think something
you know needs to be changed or follow
new trends but
we just follow our guts that's really
simple but that's kind of what it is i
mean that does take a fair bit
of stones to be able to to do that
because you've been in a bunch of
situations pretty
obviously very focused on situations in
which you've had to pivot super quickly
uh whether it is with you know call me
daddy uh or whether it is with a
particular business graduate or
controversy
so what is the is that just you just
wake up that morning like i'm making a
call we're doing it yeah i mean things
maybe not as instantaneous as that
but once we decide to do something we
really
do it and it doesn't always work and
obviously you have to know when
something's not working and probably
alright maybe this isn't the right right
avenue the right path or whatever it is
but it's just believing in yourself and
i also grow that's my personality
um even to start a business like this
you kind of have to be a risk taker
and willing to put yourself out there
and then over the years
you know barcelo's been wildly
successful uh you know
i didn't start it to get it where it is
like i just want to do my own thing
and then at some point when you have
enough success
and people are chirping you are being
like don't do this don't do that it's
like what does this person know from the
cheap seats it's
you know i'm the one who got us here so
i'm going to continue just to follow
what i think is the right thing to do so
for folks who don't know the barstool
story how did this company get started
in the first place because i had been
aware for of it for a while but it was
around a long time before i was
aware of it actually i would say it's
gained a lot of its popularity in what
last seven to ten years maybe
yeah we go through cycles so we've been
around i think 17 years now it started
as a newspaper it was a sports gambling
and like fantasy sports newspaper
that i would hand out outside subway
stations in boston um and again
i never even at the time i never thought
we would be
online or anything like that so it isn't
like this is what i thought the company
would be
but it was a four-page gambling rag and
it slowly morphed over the years
from more gambling and fantasy to more
men's lifestyle and now
i would say it's you know both we have a
lot of female content as well but it's
looking at life
not too seriously that's the goal um
from both a male and female perspective
okay so how did you decide that you were
going to start just
doing a newspaper that you printed out
and then handed out at subway stations
in boston so i i wanted to start a
business so i always knew i didn't want
to work for
somebody else i had a sales job out of
college and i had i don't know
three possible i guess business ideas
that i came up with
one was this sports gambling newspaper
the other one was a scouting company for
high school athletes who are getting
recruited and maybe aren't division one
athletes but looking for a place
to play in a software that could connect
scouts and the third was used furniture
as crazy that sounds i was always like
hey college kids throw all their
furniture away
maybe if i had a huge warehouse drive
around get the furniture for free
and this is like a different era the
internet was just kind of getting going
so let people buy this furniture that
i'm getting for free
online so it was always a business
perspective it's just like which one did
i think
was most realistic and easiest to get
started and for whatever
reason i landed on barstool that is
hysterical because i do remember being
in law school and having the exact same
idea because every year at the end of
the year you'd see these people taking
sure just tossing it directly out on the
curb hey that's free stuff right free
stuff warehouse it let people buy it
online
you have something so yeah what i
graduated was like kind of the dot-com
like boom like the economy was going
great
and ideas like that were coming out
everywhere so those are the things i
looked at
okay and then you take this newspaper
and how does it morph online and become
bigger so i used to hand out the
newspaper outside subway stations wake
up like
i don't know 4am um hand it out
go back work do sales i was doing it all
one day i handed it to a guy at south
station boston financial district and
this is probably
we started 2004 this may be 2007
and he was moving to new york city he's
like i love this this newspaper
if i move to new york i want to be able
to read it so if i build you a website
will you put the newspaper
on the website it's like if you want to
do it for free knock yourself out
this guy his name was ian white ended up
being the cto for business insider
i got super lucky so he built the
website i started putting articles and
things
like very quickly that became obvious
that would be the future of the business
i could scale it a lot faster it was
growing a lot faster
and that's where you know the internet
side of what we did came from but
at that point if you said we're a blog
people would have looked at you like 10
hands they picked what is blog never
heard of it so in a second i want to ask
you about
the sports side of the business and kind
of your passion personally about sports
first if 2021 has taught us anything so
far
you need to be using a vpn why would you
trust the tech bros with your data with
your information doesn't matter what
your politics are or who you voted for
everyone should have the right to
express themselves freely sadly the big
tech monopoly has instead opted for
silencing tactics and censorship to
fight back against big text control of
the internet
i personally use expressvpn you ever
wondered how those free to access tech
giants make all their money well
they track your searches your video
history everything you click on by
building a profile on you and then
selling off your sensitive data they
make their money when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity more difficult to
trace and sell to advertisers
what's more expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals what i
like most is how easy it is to use
it takes just one click to protect all
of your devices that's why expressvpn is
rated
number one by cnet and wired every
single human should be using a vpn
because you want to protect
your own internet privacy revoke big
text right to your data
secure your internet with the vpn i
trust for online protection visit
expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
get three extra months free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more all right so
let's talk about your interest in sports
so two of the three businesses you
mentioned off the top were both sports
oriented one was a scouting business and
the other was
what eventually became known as barstool
so
what was your interest in sports going
all the way back well i mean you're from
new england
right so i mean i was a die-hard
everything boston sports fan
played my whole life i lived in an era
growing up in boston like dan shawnee
sees a local sports writer and they
they in wei was the local radio station
and they had a hammer lock i mean a
hammer lock on how
sports fans got their information and to
be honest like dan shaws he hates the
red sox
he covers them he hates them ron bohr
just covered the patriots
he hates him so everything was lecturing
and a lot of fans didn't like it
i was a huge bill simmons fan and he
kind of
modernized or changed the way the game
worked like in the internet allowed him
to have a voice
but like the boston globe didn't hire
bill simmons like nope not right
shows you how crazy they are so it there
was this
this opening there was this window
basically for
a different type of voice to reach
sports fans and i thought maybe we could
fill it with barstool sports that's a
really interesting take because
i hadn't really thought about the fact
that there has always been this sort of
gap between how
many in the elite culture want to cover
sports and what the fan actually wants
to see from sports i remember reading
simmons in the early days and reading
his blog
and forget politics he's a terrific
writer and really talented guy and and
the way he covered the celtics i'm a
celtics fan too
growing up in l.a and the way he covered
this this is the way i want to hear
people talk about sports
he was revolutionary in that regard i
still
think the best probably pure writer when
he was on his own that he was on i think
digital city boston
and just letting it you know fly yeah
and
it was excellent we tried to get him
involved in early barcelona got nowhere
with it
but it did there was an appetite for it
in the established guard whether bei the
boston globe was so arrogant almost in
the way that they covered sports
they just they weren't open to new ideas
eventually
you know people like myself started
eating them because they just didn't
they didn't pay attention to it i wonder
if you feel like that gap is
is still there because it feels like as
bar stool grows and as alternative
sports media grows
there's still this sort of espn out
there that really is
you know covering sports in in a much
more almost stayed way you have to stay
between these lines you're not allowed
to talk about sportswear a fan would
talk about sports you have to cover
sports the way a journalist would cover
sports
and you get that also with regard to you
know sports illustrator which i
subscribed to from the time i was a kid
and then when i was in
my mid-20s i cancelled it i said i'm not
even reading about sports anymore i'm
just reading about
the kind of political takes of the
particular sports writers
i kind of want to just read about the
sports yeah that's certainly been
a huge issue lately obviously you know
espn i think is trying to they go back
and forth they're wavering on where they
land and it is a delicate
dance that they're trying to do but
there's more outlets like
us like there's no doubt our success
has been because of the fact that the
other companies were so stringent didn't
want to change
but i think in a lot of ways barcelona
has forced some change with that
because we've been able to capture such
a huge market share
uh but yeah i i'd agree with the overall
premise people
don't always want politics and sports
together yeah so i was gonna ask you a
little bit more about that so
uh obviously we've seen that the sports
have gotten overtly political in a way
that they weren't when
i was a kid there were always sports
figures who were political i mean i
remember charles barkley posing in slave
garb on the cover of sports illustrated
i remember michael jordan in the 90s
saying republicans wear sneakers too so
there's always like a touch of sure
athletes will talk politics but it never
entered sort of the field of play
until the last 10 years when you had
people doing hands up don't shoot
running onto a football field or you had
kaepernick kneeling on the sidelines
whether you like it you don't like it or
whether you have
on in the nba actual labeling of the
sidelines or labeling of the jerseys it
seems like politics which started off as
political you know athletes are just
like everybody else they can say what
they want to say on politics
it moved from that to no we as leagues
are overtly going to now push forward a
certain
number of agenda items and if you don't
like those agenda items then i guess the
sport isn't for you i mean it feels
actively alienating to a lot of folks
yeah you know my view on that
i don't i have no problem at at a point
with politics being involved in sports
because at
some level you you where
it's like where do you draw the line
because you even look at like what was
the berlin olympics
where you know they they put their hand
up like that's great like that's hitler
so they're
they're they're making a statement that
i agree with so
it it where is the line now the leagues
how i view the leagues
i don't think the leagues are looking at
it as
we're doing what we morally think is
right i've never thought that
they're doing it as how can we make the
most money
appease our fan base or do whatever like
goodell who's been back and forth who i
don't care for
there's not there's nobody on earth who
can convince me
he makes any decision based on you know
this is morally the right thing to do
you can agree morally
whether something is right or protest is
right but i just don't buy that with the
leagues they're doing it
on what they think is best for their
bottom line and that
you know that they'll find out in the
end i guess whether that was right or
wrong
so i may as well ask you now what's the
story with you and goodell obviously
yeah i hate him
the goodell story goes back uh i'm
from boston i'm a patriot fan die-hard
patriot fan
uh die-hard tom brady fan so deflategate
in which he was accused of cheating and
deflating footballs which they never
proved or came
close to proving we defended tom and we
defended him at every step and i had
more information i feel like
cadell had but when they suspended for
four games
we went and protested and had myself and
three other patriot fans who work for me
handcuffed ourselves to each other at
nfl headquarters
and demanded to sit with roger he did
say he'd
speak with the media any point we got
arrested spent a night in jail for that
that began began what i would say is one
of our true rivalries
and now if roger goodell had any uh
self-awareness
he could have poked light at this and
made a joke out of this
but he didn't and it continued to
escalate and continue to escalate i got
dragged out of the super bowl
um it was patriots ram super bowl i
bought tickets
and at halftime they literally had about
10 security guards
dragged me out in handcuffs because they
banned me from the super bowl
and it just continued for example during
covet
they had a charity event and they're
like hey whoever bids the most
will get to watch a game with roger
goodell in his basement
so i spent 250 grand i won the auction
and they nullified that so i mean it's
just been one
event after another with him uh we're
banned from all nfl events and we have a
great relationship with the patriots as
well
we we had we sell this picture with his
face
a clown which actually trump stole from
me they sell it's like the clown nose
um so we had 70 000 towels the first
time that roger goodell
showed up at gillette stadium the entire
stadium's holding them
uh it's just been an ongoing rivalry
uh that started with the flight gate
that's awesome
so belichick or brady who's responsible
for this example what a question
obviously brady just won the super bowl
so that it's given him an advantage i
don't think you can pick one of the
other i think they're both the best to
ever do it
i've said and i maintain if i could only
have one
i would take the coach i think head
football coach
in the nfl is the most important
position anywhere
brady went to a great situation like i
think if belichick coached that team
with that talent
they win every game so they're both the
best but
gun to head i would take belichick
before brady so your sights
what's the split in terms of the
audience in terms of male female like i
think it's probably like
70 30 or 65 35 at this point
so do you think that's just because of
the content or also just because of the
attitude because obviously you're just
like a
let it fly kind of dude and the site
reflects that yeah well i mean it
started as a men's site we were talking
about
the the idea behind barcelona sports the
name of it
was what guys would talk about a bar
watching sports so that was
entertainment girls sports you name it
so it was a bunch of guys doing it now
we hired a girl
early and actually had a sister site
called stool a lot
so we had barcelona sports stool a lot
the problem with stool
allah was the girl we hired became a
superstar um she was like
the first really youtube internet
sensation name's jenna marble she has
like a statue in madame tussaud
like that is how big she became and we
could find somebody good enough to
replace her
but that's why it started primarily as
you know
men there are a lot of conservatives who
worry that there's an attempt to sort of
water down
uh what men ought to be or what men
ought to do
in our society there's attempt to censor
men uh that men are sort of being told
that they need to sit down and shut up
in their interests take a backseat that
there's a sort of generalized
feminization of society what do you make
of the critique
i think that is true but with all
critiques like
that they're almost social media echo
chambers to me like that
that is percent true and one of the
things with
me that i always find fascinating is if
you ask most people off the street
like what is dave politically thinking
he's very conservative
that's not true people listen to like
what i actually say
but that sentiment of what you said
it people view barcelona they just put
me in a bucket now we've done events
that we used to do these like rays for
lack of better words and we
they were we have djs we have girls
scantily dressed they wear like booty
shorts and we have protesters come and
scream at these girls girls feminists
girls who identify themselves as
feminists
being like you shouldn't go to that
they're sexist or this that and then
we'd have these same girls
who say you know what you're sexist
because you're telling me how to think
and what i can laugh at and what i can
enjoy
as a woman i have the right to make that
decision so there is that element
but i think the majority like and i've
said this made i don't
i hate both extremes i really do i hate
the extreme left i hate the extreme
right
they should be thrown on a battlefield
and let them just like kill each other
to death
because i do what charles barkley said
the other day on tv he's like i think
the majority people
get along i believe that i truly believe
that
you have these extremes but i do agree
with what you're saying um
the watered down the culture i i firmly
believe when people have said this i
have no no problem with saying like a
girl is hot or pretty or sexy to me
that you know what that's adam and eve
type stuff like that is something so i
don't have a problem with that
that doesn't mean that i don't think
that person i just said that could be
brilliant
and the smartest person in the room but
physical attributes and things like that
you shouldn't just because you say
something's pretty that to me isn't
objectifying somebody that's kind of
like science so in a second i want to
ask you about the
the kind of wave of cancellations that
hits the culture because this goes to
if you say perfectly obvious things
sometimes you do have to be worried that
advertisers will pull
100 or stuff like that so i want to ask
you about that in one second first
it's pretty obvious when i don't get a
good night's rest i mean it really
screws
with the rest of my day the good news is
it's been a while since this has
happened
at least not due to my mattress helix
sleep they make the best mattresses
they've got a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way
you sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses that are great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus-sized folks
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you'll order the mattress
that you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix is awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
and also by gq and wired magazine just
go to helixsleep.com take that two
minute sleep quiz they will match you to
a customized mattress that'll give you
the very best sleep of your life they've
got a 10-year warranty you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free
they'll pick it up for you if you don't
love it i promise you will because i
love my own helix sleep mattress again
my wife and i took that sleep quiz
it made a mattress just for us and it is
fantastic helix is right now offering up
to two
hundred dollars off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com slash ben that's
helixsleep.com
so let's talk about the fact that if you
say anything that is remotely edgy these
days there's this deep worry that you're
going to get canceled that people online
are going to come after you and then
they'll come after your advertisers now
as it happens to us on the show all the
time people are constantly you know
beating us up this
i trend approximately once every three
weeks i think is as much as the
algorithm will allow me to trend
on twitter but at the same time uh the
real fear is that
eventually these folks will mobilize
against advertisers against paying
customers
uh and then it'll kill your business how
do you navigate that minefield
it's really hard uh you know i i'm proud
that i don't think parcel has
ever really been been beholden to which
way the wind is blowing the political
climate
if you have a real fan base which we do
when we've cultivated over almost two
decades
it allows you to withstand that because
i know and i've known this for a long
time if i went to our readers who have
been a lot of them for a long time said
listen
we either have to cater to what the
advertisers want
or we have to be us but you may have to
pay more and we may have to come up
may buy a t-shirt pay model i know what
our crowd would say
so it does not bother me that way
because our audience is real
and we just stay true to ourselves the
second let advertisers
dictate what you do or you beholden to
them
you lose your voice you're kind of dead
so that that's been what's
allowed us to stay true um basically to
who we are
so one of the things that you've been
doing is you're out there really helping
out small businesses in a way that
nobody else is and that's been an
initiative since covet uh
so what gave you the idea that you were
just going to step into the breach and
you were going to just help out these
small businesses that have been
destroyed by kobe yeah so
it was towards i think it was around
december when i started this and
basically new york city shut down indoor
dining
again and you know as somebody who
started a business
and can certainly identify with how much
work it
i mean barcelona was my work's life i
spent 10 years before we made any money
i just couldn't imagine not having that
decision so as i'm prone to do i went on
a rant and put it on instagram
uh and then somebody challenged me like
hey big mouth
instead of just talking about it why you
do something about it and that was the
initiative like all right
we like to control when we do charity
which we've done a lot of
because i don't necessarily trust
everybody that the money is getting
directly to who it needs so we came up
with the bar stool fund
i put 500 000 of my own money in
solicited donations from
people i know who may be wealthy
whatever tom brady's of the world
aaron rodgers whoever i may have been
lucky enough to you know
form relationships and to our readers
said hey
we're doing this if you guys have money
to donate any amount helps
and then we simultaneously said if
you're a business and you just need to
bridge this gap because for
a lot of the restaurants and bars it was
all small business but a lot of the
restaurant industry
they just need warm weather you know
they need to be able to open outside and
get things going
solicit uh send in a reason what you
need and we'll try to help as many
people as we can
so i think we raised about 40 million
dollars and helped countless businesses
we started doing facetime videos by
accident basically the first company we
helped
the girl who liz gonzalez who who helps
go through the emails and submissions
it's like this person specifically said
they're a huge fan of you dave just
surprise him with a call
so i did and when we gave him the money
the reaction was so overwhelming
that i knew we had to capture it moving
forward because that would drive the
donations
and then it just kind of took off and
you know
it was one of those things it's so
obvious that small business was dying
because of covid and that nothing was
being done to help them
it was just common sense but once you
actually
see the people and just it's
everyday like americans and how much it
meant to get
it could be ten thousand dollars like
that's what they need just to get over
the hump
it it that's what drove it and in a
weird way
there's so much crap that was going on
in the country and has been for a little
bit
this is something that everybody should
have been
behind no matter what because it's just
it didn't matter if you're a democrat
republican if a small business owner
we're just helping you get through this
thing so it was finally i think
something that had a positive message
and
even though a lot of people don't like
me even the people who didn't like me
got quiet for a little bit because
they they'd wait so can you argue with
that exactly yeah right
i mean you personally helped out one of
the uh one of the
my my favorite kosher restaurant in
chicago and i saw that online i was like
yeah kenny kenny over there excellent
excellent italian beef
it says that was really i mean it was
cool to see and i know that i can't
again you couldn't find a single person
who was anti it did speak to
i think uh some broader trends with with
the treatment of small business in the
country
i mean you started a business out of
nothing we started a business
out of nothing and it seemed like for a
lot of people who were stumping in favor
of we need to shut everything down and
we need to keep it shut down forever
there are people now who are saying
we need to keep everything shut down
forever but they just don't understand
how small businesses operate or what it
means to actually put your life's work
into a small business so then it's like
okay well you lost your business you
just go start a business next year it's
like well that's not how businesses
work at all correct and and i said in my
rant
i do believe this obviously it's easier
said than done but if you told me after
10 years
kova is going to hit and i lose what i
built
i would have been like i'm gonna risk my
life trying to save this to me this is i
don't want to go work for somebody else
i can't really start over like you said
it's not that easy this is my life's
work
i've poured everything into it i want
the chance to save it
and and i said that from the beginning
with covet and i you know as it
developed or whatnot
it's not taking anything away from how
serious it is or
isn't but i couldn't stand not letting a
business owner
decide how they want to handle their
future and frankly in like a restaurant
i know kovid's there if i want to go
into the restaurant that's up to me
that's how i felt about it but i just to
not
give these people let them control their
own destiny after
some of these businesses we have were
around for 40 years grandfathers
generally it's
it was insane to me it remains insane to
me
well unless you want to give them money
which we weren't doing
it you know they weren't nothing was
being done so that combo
i just never understood well so what
you're talking about in terms of
personal autonomy you can see why
conservatives might be uh
a hundred percent i mean there's a very
conservative idea that basically listen
you get to make your own choices in life
you want to go into that restaurant and
risk covey because you feel like eating
there
go ahead that would be that's it that's
a you thing and if you want to keep your
business running then then
you know go for it so there is no doubt
that there's things that i'll say that
will be conservative
um on the other side i want to get well
super socially liberal
so like anything on the social aspect of
it
i'm generally in favor like you know gay
what gay marriage and things like that
all
for it all let people if it doesn't
affect me do whatever you want you're a
libertarian
i am a libertarian that's exactly what i
am uh yeah socially liberal financially
conservative so that's where i land yeah
join the club man i mean
well to be honest that's what i'm saying
i think normal people are like
that's how i look at it uh our
libertarians mo there's
a lot more commonalities and even like
an issue which i don't like to wait into
like
black lives matter for for example i
think there's a ton of credibility
to how african americans are trading
this country you look at the capital
i think if those are all black people
who are rushing the capital they would
have gotten shot like
i believe that in my heart so there's
racism here now
do i think blm got taken advantage of
there's issues like well
i think we're going a little too far
with it yeah so nothing's as
like black and white no pun intended
there as it seems so
unfortunately i think a lot gets
politicized and
you know things that we should be
getting along on we end up
not but there's no doubt libertarian if
i identified would be what it is
so one aspect of that libertarianism is
obviously you have an app now that's a
sports gambling app yep and uh and it's
getting approved what state by state how
does this process actually work
so yeah sports gambling exactly like
weed uh marijuana
it it used to be illegal everywhere
except vegas
and they overturned whatever statute
that was and said this
is now a state issue so each state
decides whether they want to allow it
and how it will be handled and things of
that nature
it's getting passed quickly because the
states need money because of cover and
all that
so we are involved in this and as
somebody who grew up loving gambling
so it's like my dream thing to be
involved in so currently
if you went we have barcelona sports
book it's legal in
michigan it's legal in illinois and it's
legal in pennsylvania
and soon probably like eight more states
okay so you have all this stuff going on
and then you've got the the entire
podcast sphere so run through how all
these podcasts get bolted on because how
did you get up in the podcast space so
podcast
is one of the things i missed on my
brain we had a guy kevin clancy was
doing it years ago he's like oh
podcasting is like i don't know how
you're gonna make money doing that but
good luck
and then slowly uh that became
successful and we started adding more
podcasts
we have the biggest sports podcast part
of my take which is gigantic
um we have the biggest hockey podcast
spitting chiclets
then we have like call her daddy which
you mentioned which is a giant
like beast of a podcast for women um
raunchy but good we basically look for
unique people and let them just do their
thing
okay so now i have to ask you to walk me
through the call her daddy controversy
because obviously that one blew up the
world we'll get to that in just one
second
first let's talk about being a
responsible human if you want to be a
responsible human you need
life insurance you got family they need
the income stream if god forbid you
applause well here's the problem
finding a good life insurance program
kind of tough very often people do it by
word of mouth that is not the smartest
way to do it the smartest way to do it
policy genius policy genius can help you
compare top insurers in one place and
save 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
getting started is super simple first
you head on over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes to
find your best price
since their licensed agents work for you
not the insurance companies there's no
hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of everything soup to nuts
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google all the benefits of policy genius
the comparison tool
the handling of paperwork the unbiased
advice totally free to use
go check out policy genius today because
they will make your life a lot easier
policy genius can promise
you won't leave their website feeling
foolish instead save 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes feel good knowing if something
happens your loved ones will be taken
care of go to policygenius.com
to get started today policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
really important to get it right
alrighty so the call her daddy
controversy walk me through that because
that obviously blew up the internet yeah
so there were two girls we hired
um together and there were no names they
had no followings they had nothing
uh and they just started this podcast
called
call her daddy i knew who alex cooper
was one of the hosts
and i saw her sizzle reel basically as
like oh this is
i haven't seen anything quite like this
met her and i basically like
who made this for you she's like i did
it's like what do you mean it was super
slick
she's you know i'm like you did the
editing you did all of it yeah i taught
myself
and did all that once she said that it's
like okay we
want to bring this over because this
isn't just some you know
idiot doing it somebody who has a plan
and what she wants to do and the thing
just
blew up she made us hire her friend
basically
who did it with her who was at i think
merrill lynch or a finance company
and the thing went enormously big now we
hired them
each for three-year contracts there they
and pay them each i think 70 grand
it got so big we renegotiate it gave
them a new deal
and within a year they're each making
about half a million they could have
been making
ton more if they did this independently
would it have would anybody have known
what it is who knows i look at it like a
talent like a sports contract like
if we sign a rookie or somebody who's
nobody knows who they are and they hit
100 home runs at the all-star break
and you're playing for the red sox you
can't be like guess what i'm gonna go
play for the yankees now you gotta wait
until your contract's over
they didn't necessarily feel that way
and they started a plan and hatch a plan
to basically break the contract with us
go do their own thing there was this guy
from hbo who was involved
who is the boyfriend of not alex the
other guy
and it turned into a big a big he said
she said it was they were telling their
side i was telling mine
and eventually the two of them i offered
them a sweetheart deal it was in the
middle of covid
and we needed them to work because they
sell a ton of merch make a lot of money
for the company and i didn't want to lay
anybody off
they got a deal that they could only be
offered during covet times they could
keep the ip
which we owned and um i shortened their
contract
they couldn't agree on signing that
which is insane alex wanted to sign it
sophia did not we cut a deal with
alex sophia went her own way and that's
where it is now alex has been
wildly successful um but it made big
news because it was so popular and i
also
hijacked the podcast so they they
stopped doing their work
they they weren't putting it out and i
had enough and finally i just went on
their feed
and i said hey this is dave portney a
lot of their fans like who the heck is
this guy
and i just said exactly what was
happening now
my crowd and people who know me for
better for worse i'm very blunt and
honest
like if people who don't like me they'll
never be like oh he lied or he's
dishonest those would be
he's a jerk and he's too blunt so when i
say something people know i'm generally
telling the truth
that worked in that in that case as well
so is it's that kind of stuff where
people where i asked you before is it
like you just make a split second
decision you're like you know what i'm
just taking over the podcast feed today
or
it was a long time coming i mean this
controversy was months
and it just got to the point something
has to be done
and i make this a decision and i do it
so
i want to ask you about the you know the
there's this recent controversy where
there's a sex tape with you that was
released
third one third one right so i i feel
like and the stock price took a hit so
first of all i have to say you're a very
confident person that you've made this
many sex tapes
something that i enjoy doing i'm much
more careful they're all very old so i
never dreamed
like hey people are going to want to
watch me have sex that was just not
something that crossed my mind that was
it just like
one day i'll break this out for the
grandkids or what was the no we do it
for it
okay it's like you know i spice it up in
the bedroom a little bit but it was
meant for just the girl and i
and nobody else uh obviously that's
changed so
um but yes anyways and anyway so the
question was
the the the stock price took a hit
because of that
right and why i mean again as you say
this was the third
sex tape that came out it's not like
anybody gives a damn
yeah who knows i don't know why that the
only thing i could think is maybe people
are super smart on wall street which i
don't necessarily
think that's always the case but like oh
this could cause a buying opportunity
like people are going to see it'll go
down we'll rebuy when it goes down
but other than i don't know it's um you
know it's two consensual adults
having sex and as far as i know unless
you have evidence to the contrary
we won't be here if people weren't
having sex so it's not like everybody
has sex or else we wouldn't be here
so who cares uh that's also the dave
portney i don't give
a crap about much i very much in the
girl didn't either
i would care very much if the girl cared
that's the only thing i care about
because whoever releases this on the
internet and we haven't been able to
find i'd like to make an example out of
that person
so it stops they don't think of the not
about me they're trying to get at me
but they don't think of the
repercussions of the other person who's
a nobody
and that can like severely hurt somebody
a female if she's like oh my god i don't
want to be seen like this
so that that is the part that whoever
releases this
really doesn't think about it at all so
you mentioned a second ago the dudes on
wall street
uh and uh what did you make of the whole
gamestop
robin hood situation because you're
pretty vocal about that i am
i was stunned by it i lost 700 000 on
gamestop or not gamestop on amc but it
was the same like
they stopped the trading i i didn't even
know you could do that
i i literally didn't know you could just
say hey you can
sell the stock but you can't buy it they
eventually essentially tank the stock
price
and nobody will ever convince me if the
shoe was on the other foot
and you know the hedge funds and the
billionaires
were making a ton of money in a volatile
nature
that it would be stopped to be like oh
you guys are making too much
the little guy's getting killed but
that's what happened here
and do i think they're phone calls made
and things behind
closed doors and if you've seen the show
billions steve cohen even
is tied into these companies i think
there was shady stuff that went on and i
think the little guy got screwed for the
most part
to save billionaires and short squeeze
has been going on for a very very
long time this is essentially just a
publicly created short squeeze
against uh people who they thought were
over leveraged in the market right so
yes
it's it is pretty amazing that that they
shut it down i interviewed vlad
he came on i think he see and that's the
ceo of robin hood i think he sees me
as a conduit to their retail traders and
they're trying to go public and all this
so
as a way to build trust back up is like
let me talk to dave
and i'm no expert on a lot of things he
was talking about
i at first thought he was a criminal
i've changed to be
he was inadequately prepared and
borderline and competent
because the the the it was bubbling
like what was going on with gamestop and
amc it wasn't something that just you
snapped and it happened
it was over the course of a couple days
so to not be
ready for it that that to me is
incompetence but he brought up a fair
point
he's like we if we folded it would have
been worse
for our clients at the point where they
were losing money on every single trade
because
they'd actually over leverage themselves
in order to fill the contract correct
but i still
no one will ever convince me if the rich
guys
are benefiting nobody calls a timeout
and says hold on we're going to make
sure that
that i don't believe so along the same
lines you a bitcoin guy not a bitcoin
guy
i'm i don't own any so i bought it at 11
and this and then i sold it quickly at
11 000 because i just couldn't wrap my
brain around i had the winklevoss twins
explaining to me what it was
they told me a story that sounded like
cockamamie to me it's like
elon musk is mining gold from outer
space it's going to rain down like
i don't know what's going on here i'm
going to stick with things i know
the timing of me doing that it went
bananas i mean the
within a month of me selling it is when
this rocket ship happened
it's interesting to me the bitcoin the
crypto people will taunt me
every single day about not being in it i
love the way they handle social media i
think it's hilarious it's kind of my
vein
making the memes and all this stuff but
currently i'm not involved
so in a second i want to ask you about
one of the other things that you do you
go around eating pizza
at different small shops i'll ask you
about that in a second first you may
have noticed that they are currently
blowing out the currency we are spending
more money than god has ever created we
are spending more money than any
government in human history
so do you think that our nation's
economy is going to be insulated from
joe biden's massive tax increases
i don't think so there's only one way to
protect your savings do what over 10 000
other smart investors have done
convert a portion of your retirement
account into gold and silver with birch
gold when inflation hits
and it's going to at some point or
another gold and silver are your safe
haven
and birch gold group those are the
people i trust to help you convert an
ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
through april 30th on qualifying
purchases when you open a precious
metals ira with birch gold they'll send
you a free home safe
birch gold they're the people i buy my
gold from you can trust them as well
again you should diversify everybody in
the stock market will tell you to
diversify but why wouldn't you diversify
outside the stock market
into some precious metals text ben to 47
47 47 for your free information kit on
precious metals iras or to speak with
the birch gold representative today
with 10 000 customers they have an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau
countless five star reviews they can
help you too text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free safe with
qualifying purchase
all righty so let's talk about uh the uh
the one bite
pizza sure stick so how did this begin
so that began
i won't say about five years ago we had
a debate in our office if you could eat
one food the rest of your life what
would it be one of the guys who works
for us said
burritos i think his theory was like
breakfast burritos
i said pizza and then we actually did it
so
for about a month i only ate pizza every
single meal
i was eating it so much i like grease
coming on my toes it was cool
but i was eating it so much people start
building how is it and i'm like all
right i'll just take one bite and give
you a quick score
and it just resonated it was obvious it
resonated so
even after the contest ended i continued
to do it we're at boston
in boston at the time and when i moved
to new york i said i'll just try
every single pizza place in new york and
it's one of those things people still
see me in the street
and they'll just think i'm the pizza guy
like they don't even know i do anything
else like oh there goes the pizza guy
so it is uh probably the single most
popular thing i do
although i have to say that uh i i did
get a kick out of the
my co-religionist spotting you on the
street knowing exactly who you were
uh in fairfax and one of them bar
mitzvahing you on this yeah bar mitzvah
me it was
weird timing because he so that was
filmed like weeks before
my sex tape was released and he was
rapping like
yeah yeah joke i'm like this looks like
a fetish video
it came out the same day so it was set
me up for some bad
bad jokes are you jewish i am okay so
what do your parents think of all this
they haven't talked to me about the most
recent sex tape the first sex tape is
that what you're asking this yeah
yeah i mean yeah i'm not probably better
than that yeah the first one
they asked me uh whether my dad he's
like did you do this on purpose are you
trying to be like kim kardashian i'm
like are you crazy
uh of course not um but you know
they've come to a role with the punches
i think
my dad was the type of guy he he'd send
me uh
if he saw a story on the internet he'd
fax it to me
so he he was not necessarily the most
savvy tech guy
but and it took him a while to realize
hey this thing is working barstool
they're they're proud but occasionally
sex tape will be collateral damage to
having you be successful i guess
so let's talk for a second about you
know what what does the future look like
not just
for bar stool but for you so we'll start
with barstool what do you think bar
stool looks like
ten years from now which way are you
looking to grow here yeah you know i get
asked that all the time and i'm always
reluctant to answer because
if you told me tick tock was around like
six months ago i've been a you're crazy
so there's so many trends and technology
changes so quick i think one of the
things that makes
bar stool bar stool is we won't be set
in our ways and we'll adapt quick so
what does the world look like in 10
years i don't know i have no
clue i know we want to continue to be on
brand in the sense of
trying to take life not too seriously um
and that's really what it's for
and you know have some fun and make
jokes and things of that nature
and eat the big guys soup who who take
things too seriously
um for me personally right now i'm super
focused on getting barcelona
and the gambling stuff going that is a
big part of what was bought
and just continuing to find talent and
make barcel relevant
um i think the biggest compliment
someone gave barcelo we've been cutting
edge
cool and relevant for almost two decades
there
aren't too many brands who can maintain
kind of that like yeah they're edgy
vibe but we have for two decades so are
you concerned i mean i sort of asked
this earlier but are you concerned that
as the culture decides that jokes are
forbidden
that that's going to be bad for your
business or you think it's going to
provide an opportunity to open wider
well i don't know that that's going to
continue you know trump broke so many
people's brains
i'm curious to see what the next couple
years are like because i he just had
people
like everybody who complained about
something we a joke we made
and this isn't 99.9 of the time
this was 100 time if i looked at their
twitter profile it was political
underneath what they said about me
it was politics 100 of the time
so maybe that goes away and opens up the
flip side is
there is an audience that appreciates
and it's not even left or right it's
kind of both
like i like how these guys aren't
backing down um and our audience allows
us to do that
so people have always asked why do you
fight back or why do you push back
or why just shut up when someone takes a
shot at you that you feel is unfair
it's like i'm not going to do that like
i i will never throw the first punch but
if you
throw a shot at me on twitter out of the
clouds
it's not my responsibility to protect
you i
i don't feel that way i haven't felt
that way since day one and i don't feel
it now
but that's what all these people do
they'll throw grenades
and then they'll cry when you're like
well we're shooting back now
it's like why'd you throw the grenade so
and i've offered this is i know it's
kind of cliche
i'll talk to anybody if you have a
problem with me i'll talk to you anytime
anyplace anywhere
you can bring a hundred people and i'll
debate you by myself
because i'm confident now are there
jokes i've made that i wish i didn't and
are
perceived differently now of course but
i've been doing this for 20 years
so i'll go through point by point by
point everything i've ever said and done
so am i maybe i wish i could do that but
i know my character
and our intent has always been to make
people laugh period
so you mentioned trump and obviously
trump has been the political
400 pound gorilla in the room 800 pound
gorilla in the room for
for a while here so what did you make of
of trump and what was it like
interviewing him
that was surreal interviewing him
because i've never interviewed anybody
before so
you know i found out they asked me to do
it the day before
it's like all right yeah cool i'm gonna
go to the white house and do it great
um he was super nice to me uh
and you know i thought there's an
element of
my personality and he got it he gets
attacked so much probably that his
hackles go out
and almost like what i just said oh
you're going to attack me i'm going to
be a real jerk back to you
now is it always presidential probably
not there's things he did
that i like and i think he's so unusual
and then there's things he did
where it's like that makes it hard for
me
to support him and like the
charlottesville riots when he's like
there's bad people on both sides
to me it's like yeah that was like the
kkk you gotta like say that and
be more open to that i think the way he
handled the capital
was really bad so there's things he did
that really bad
but again it's so two-sided on every
like the the democrats being like let's
all get along now and
you got to support the president's like
well you didn't do that so why should
they do that
so it just sucks both sides suck um
but he's not a black and white guy
that's for sure and i do think
he he knew what he was doing
most of the time so you know if he's
going into a state where he thinks he
can say things that gets his base behind
him he'll do it
he's not dumb he's doing it but does it
help unity and things like that
probably not so you guys are still
located in new york is that going to be
for the long haul considering which way
new york is going right now
i don't know i mean where are we going
to go massachusetts
which isn't probably much better like
tax wise so we're an east coast company
or an east coast grind like that down
here in florida man what are you doing
no i couldn't take my company here i'm
going to be here but i got a young
company
and to see my guys strolling down south
beach at 4am like
that we won't have to worry about taxes
because we won't be making any money so
we got to find that balance on the
personal level
uh how old are you now you're a little
44. okay so you're 44. so
recently turned got it okay so so i'm
recently turned 37.
okay i have three kids uh they are
they're seven four and a baby
uh so you got kids in your future or
like i'm not gonna be your parents
what are you doing yeah no no no kids
right now in the future because i don't
have a girlfriend so i wha
i was married so i was married for five
years dave for five years she's still
actually my best friend
um you know i take it day by day
it's like am i do i wake up be like damn
i need kids no
if i met somebody that's like oh this
person i want to have kids with great
but i don't lose sleep over it and then
you mentioned that you were jewish
growing up what's your
religious kind of thought now did you
ever think about it i mean i'm still
jewish
that doesn't change i go up on mitzvot
but i'm not like a practicing
jew um you know religion i think is
great if it's used the right way i think
a lot of times
over you know history it's been used in
a weird way like how politics
like for power and things like that
as basic as it sounds it's like be nice
that
that is a religion i think everybody
should just basically have
i think the widespread perception of you
is that you're
not not total perception but there is
this kind of media creative perception
that like you're the guy who's out of
control then nobody can control you like
that you don't like that
where do you feel it can benefit um at
times
but you know the people that that's
part of the reason we did the deal in
seoul because you bring in people that
bring credibility to it
um yeah i guess i don't mind the
i'm not nearly as wild as people think i
am but that's fine
uh i don't give a much thought i guess
people are gonna think what they think
and to be honest the people who don't
like me
i give them a hundred dollars and
they'll be like why don't you give me a
thousand like they're just never gonna
like me
that's what i was gonna ask because your
company has you were telling me earlier
like 250 employees
companies that are running on the seat
of the pants don't typically have 250
employees and do hundreds of millions of
dollars here in business
yeah and maybe it's not as seat of our
pants as i'm making it seem like erica
nardinis
who our ceo is brilliant and we have a
lot of really smart people working there
but everyone just has a similar mindset
not afraid to take chances
and you know we haven't changed what's
worked
and what's worked is us being truly
authentic
uh there's been so many stories now
really i feel like became a huge
buzzword uh in media
the last couple years and i always hear
stories like someone told me espn had a
a meeting on how to be authentic it's
like well you already lost like you're
having
a meeting on how to be authentic we
don't do that we're just ourselves
we don't handle pr differently like i
mean
we just do things in a different
manner like we have we do have pr people
they don't even talk to me because
when someone asks me about a sex tape or
a controversy
i answer honestly like who cares i had
sex like big deal
um so that's just who we are i feel like
that is sort of the new wave in business
though because
i will say we have a very slim
management structure at daily wire too
and one of the things we pride ourselves
on is the fact that we can react
incredibly quickly
whereas a lot of these bigger companies
it takes a while for them to turn the
ship if they're headed in a particular
direction
it's just going to take them forever to
steer that ship and once they're
committed to that course it feels like
they they're kind of they're kind of
done yeah and there's red tape
and there's people who you know jobs may
be the line if you make the wrong
decision like we dealt with that all the
time early barstool
i knew we were way bigger than people
thought we were but
traditional advertisers god forbid
something goes wrong
do you want to be the guy who says i
chose them the reward wasn't worth the
risk for somebody
who's working in nine to five and you
know that's just something they're not
interested in
as a business owner you obviously had to
run in with the nlrb we were talking
about this a little bit earlier
yeah i i have a similar experience with
the nlrb where i made
uh a joke about firing employees if they
tried to
run my company in terms of politics but
you had the same experience and then a
lot of me went after you
yeah yeah there's a company i hate
there's a couple of them there's a bunch
of them
um and that's probably why by the way
people because they identify super left
and i
they're the worst um absolutely no fun
club
and i made fun of them because they
basically went bankrupt
and all their writers lost their jobs
and they had this great union
and we don't have a union and no one
wants to leave our company
and i made fun of them like hey that
union did great for you guys huh you all
got fired
um total joke and it became an issue
aoc who sucks
uh jumped in on this without any
knowledge
she was just looking she used it i think
as a fundraiser
like she put me in her fundraising
letter the next day shocking she did
fundraising i can't no
no and i know she didn't know
anything about what she was talking
about it but it made it a much bigger
issue
and then we have people coming at me
it's like you you don't even
the analogy i use with us a lot of times
is going to a comedy show that you don't
know who the comedian is
you didn't buy a ticket you walk in you
hear a joke you walk out in the street
you're like you never believe what this
guy said
without mentioning you were in a comedy
club that's
what i feel happens and that's kind of
what aoc did
um so you know
i it wasn't even the whatever they're
called like they didn't know what was
going on either all these people issued
complaints
and once aoc makes it seem like it's a
real thing which it's
not it would be like taking a joke from
american pie and be like oh my god so
once it became that they said well the
end result of this
was i had to send a letter oh no an
email to my company
saying i was kidding which by the way i
was so i didn't care doing it
we're having the same issue and uh we're
probably going to fight it all the way
like well
because because they basically once i
tweeted out that
members of my company i'd be happy to
fire them if they if they wish to take
the company in a different editorial
direction
uh which is not by the way a unionizable
issue we i issued a tweet saying we
follow all of the nlra we follow all of
the applicable law and lrb still sent us
a letter asking me
to take down the original tweet and then
apologize for ever having made a joke
about this sort of stuff i'm never going
to apologize for making a joke about the
source have you
are you kidding me yeah it's like what
you said like i i you know
i didn't take a vacation day for 10
years like i worked my ass off for
barcelona i really did
and you know i hired people i put my own
money back into it risk it
hire people we have a great thing but
it's like
now you're going to tell me what i have
to do on a talent business by the way
i always said that we're talking about
people who
if you don't think you're making enough
money with me and you're talented
then you can just not resign with me and
if you're as talented as you think you
are
and you're being underpaid somebody else
will pay you if somebody else
won't pay you you're probably getting
what you deserve or maybe more with me
so like you don't need a union for what
we're doing
um but it was more i was just making fun
of this company i hate it
and what do you think is the future of
sports because what we've seen over the
past few years
is the viewership on sports is just
hitting the skids i mean it's
really really bad except for you know
maybe mma which continues to do
really really well i think in part
because dana white runs his company
kind of like you run your company or i
run my company he's just like you know
this is my company i'm doing exactly
whatever the hell i want and if you
don't like it you can shove it
but all these other big kind of sporting
conglomerates nfl nba mlb
they seemed like they were in growth
mode some of them nfl and nba
particularly
five years ago but it seems like now
they are running into some real
headwinds
what do you think is the future of
sports here it's hard to say you know i
i
and it's hard to actually in my mind
pull out necessarily what's happening
like e-gaming for example people grow up
the kids
nowadays are doing different things like
i used to go play wiffle ball and
baseball every day now people are
playing video games
and that's a world that's exploring tick
tock and things like that the kids
they're making videos of dancing in
front of mirrors they're not doing
traditional things and i think that
effect
plays out on ratings and things like
that
i really don't know i i i mean i think
the sports will be around football's got
a little bit probably an issue
with like not only whether it be
political stuff but actual like
concussions and things of that nature
and taking hitting out of the game
i don't know i think i think it really
varies sports and sport but
i couldn't imagine a world where they're
not here let's say you have 100 bucks
you got to put it on a sport
and this is the sport that's the growth
sport for the next 10 15 years which one
do you put it on
mba i think they have the best
commissioner
the nba uh obviously like a lot of other
sports they took a hit over the last
year
got very very political and now
obviously there are a lot of critics
people like me i'm very critical of the
nba i make no bones about this
you know you got major players in the
nba who are spending
you know all day talking about the how
much america is a systemically racist
country while pulling down 50 million
a year we're talking about wage
differentials well women in the nba are
making 215 grand a year and they're
making 49 million dollars a year there's
hype
i mean hypocritical lebron's like the
all-time with like in their stances on
china and what goes on so i agree with
that
but i think they got the best
commissioner and i think they're most
uh internet savvy okay that would be why
i picked them what do you think the
sales are going to do in the playhouse
this year may as well ask you that
uh i i think they could get hot we look
before the show you and i
there's about four or five teams cramped
for that seven or eight
i don't think there's any beast in the
like the sixers are one
brooklyn could be a problem you don't
know what happened if durant's healthy
and kyrie like isn't having mental
issues
um they'd probably be my favorite if
they're healthy but
i think they can make a run so you're in
the cultural space it seems like there's
all right you're oddly enough this very
culturally unifying figure you mentioned
right at the very top
there are a lot of people sort of across
the spectrum who love barstool who love
what you're doing
but it feels politically from where i
say because that's what i do every day
the country's falling apart
it feels like people are polarizing like
they don't get along uh you represent
the sort of vast middle
which direction do you think is going to
win out do you think it's going to be
you know the
the country falls apart or you think
that there is this center that is going
to hold or
just people too apathetic i think the
center will hold i i just think there's
too many people who get along
um then don't there's more that unites
us than doesn't
and one of the things people always
mention
is uh i don't know anyone else does it
better i don't think so so it's very
easy
here to criticize and there's no doubt
there's problems there's problems
in every country but then you're like
all right go pick where you want to go
like
what other country do you want to go to
that is this utopia that you think
exists because it doesn't um so i think
the center will
hold i don't think it would be good if
trump ran for president again because i
think he is
like i think the republicans can find
people who unite the country if you're a
republican
you can get a lot of things you want
done without
somebody that whether he's right or
wrong he's going to divide again but so
i hope that doesn't happen to be totally
honest i want to ask a few
final questions here starting with
you're giving advice to somebody who's
about to start a business what are the
the key pieces of advice but if you'd
like to hear dave porter's answers you
have to be a daily wire member head on
over to dailywire.com click subscribe
you can hear the rest of our
conversation
over there everybody go take a look at
the bar stool shows there are a bunch
there's bound to be one for you plus
download that bar stool sportsbook app
go check out the barstool fun they're
supporting small businesses right now
they're awesome
dave thank you so much for stopping by
that was fun
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]